.
Was macht uns zur Frau oder zum Mann?
Der Körper oder das eigene Empfinden?
* Melancholischer Popsong:
"Getting Older" von Billie Eilish *
Die meisten Menschen
wissen schon früh,
ob sie ein Mädchen
oder ein Junge sind.
Von aussen ist dagegen
nicht unbedingt erkennbar,
welches Geschlecht
eine Person empfindet.
Denn nicht bei allen Menschen
stimmt das äusserliche Geschlecht
mit dem gefühlten Geschlecht überein.
Davon handelt diese Geschichte.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# ... 'cause the strangers seem
to want me more than anyone before.
# Anyone before.
# Too bad they're usually deranged.
Wenn ich mich selbst betrachte,
verstehe ich schon,
wieso sie mich seltsam findet.
Es ist auch kein Wunder,
dass sie mich seltsam findet.
Denn ... ich bin halt nicht
wie alle anderen.
Soraya ist ein Transmädchen.
D.h., sie fühlt sich als Mädchen,
ist anatomisch aber ein Junge,
13 Jahre alt.
Die Klasse kannte den Teenager
bis vor Kurzem als Josué.
Mit dem Coming-out
wurde aus ihm Soraya.
Jetzt habe ich viel eher das Gefühl,
dass ich richtig im Leben bin.
Als ich als Josué
noch zu den Jungen gehörte,
war ich oft alleine in den Pausen.
Die Jungs spielten halt Fussball,
während die Mädchen
ihre eigenen Dinge machten
und nicht wollten,
dass ein Junge dabei ist.
Ich sass oft alleine da.
Jetzt, mit den Mädchen,
macht es viel mehr Spass.
Was bedeutet es,
mit 13 ein neues Leben
im anderen Geschlecht zu beginnen?
Wie geht ihre Familie damit um?
Wird es Soraya gelingen,
ihren Platz im Leben zu finden?
Um das herauszufinden,
werden wir sie und ihre Familie
sechs Jahre mit der Kamera begleiten.
Ich mag Rosarot nicht, weil es
eine typische Mädchenfarbe ist.
Ich mochte Rosarot schon immer.
Es ist zwar etwas kitschig ...
... aber mir gefällt es halt.
Es ist mir egal,
ob es auch anderen gefällt.
Hoffentlich ist es dann trocken
ein wenig heller.
Ich weiss,
was wir machen könnten.
Wir könnten noch
weisse Punkte reinmalen.
Nein!
Sich weiblich
oder männlich wahrzunehmen,
hat nichts mit Sexualität zu tun,
sondern mit Geschlechtsidentität.
Ist die Wand schon trocken?
Diese ist nicht messbar.
Nicht der Wand entlang.
Nicht zu viel,
nur noch ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen mehr
auf diese Seite.
Als Junge fühlte sich Soraya
schon lange vor dem Coming-out
im falschen Körper.
Als Junge war es irgendwie so ...
Keine Ahnung, es war seltsam.
Irgendwie eklig.
Jetzt ist es viel -
keine Ahnung - schöner.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
(Mann) Sharlyn, wer ist das?
- Das ist Josué.
Und wer ist Josué?
Ist das deine Schwester?
Der Bruder.
- Dein Bruder.
(Frau) Wir freuten uns darüber,
dass das dritte Kind ein Junge ist.
Und sie freuten sich
über ihren kleinen Bruder.
Jetzt bist du schon drei Monate alt.
Die Mutter und der Vater haben
unterschiedliche Erinnerungen daran,
wann Josué begann,
sich untypisch zu verhalten.
Es begann schon
mit drei oder vier Jahren,
als er immer wieder sagte,
er sei ein Mädchen.
Ich sagte dann:
"Nein, du bist ein Junge".
Ich war auch stolz darauf,
einen Jungen zu haben.
Mit der Zeit merkte ich,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Wieso sagt er das so oft?
Hallo.
Da gab es bestimmt zwei,
drei Situationen in der Kindheit.
als sich der kleine Josué
in Mädchenkleider stürzte.
Und das hier, Josué, das ist schön.
- Nein!
Nur für ein Foto. Komm!
Wow!
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
Er fühlte sich offensichtlich wohl,
das fiel mir schon auf.
Aber da macht man sich
keine Gedanken als Eltern.
Ich wollte ihn ins Fussball-
oder Judotraining schicken.
Aber er wollte ins Ballett
oder anderweitig tanzen.
Mit der Zeit realisierten wir,
dass er nicht nur
wegen des Tanzens dorthin wollte,
sondern v.a. wegen der Tutus,
die die Mädchen trugen.
Ich mochte Mädchenkleider
schon immer lieber,
weil ich sie einfach schön fand.
Es war lange gar kein Thema,
ob jemand ein Junge
oder ein Mädchen war.
Erst in der 3. oder 4. Klasse
realisierte ich,
dass es Unterschiede gibt.
Da fühlte ich mich eher als Mädchen
denn als Junge.
Kaum lernte er schreiben,
schrieb er mir einen Brief.
"Liebes Mami,
ich hoffe, du bist nicht enttäuscht
und hast mich trotzdem noch lieb,
wenn ich dir sage,
dass ich ein Mädchen
und kein Junge bin."
Ich dachte: "Ja, ja ..."
"Eine weitere verrückte Idee."
Ich nahm das nicht ernst,
das muss ich so sagen.
* Ruhige Gitarrenmusik *
Was mag in diesem kleinen Kopf
vorgehen?
Schon als Josué
noch ganz klein war ...
... habe ich ihn nie verstanden.
Seine Gedanken
und seine Handlungen ...
... konnte ich
nur schwer nachvollziehen.
Hast du eine Erklärung dafür?
Äh ... Ja.
Ich glaube,
es hat schon damit zu tun,
dass ich nicht
der leibliche Vater bin.
Sie hat einen leiblichen Vater,
der ist weit weg in Brasilien.
Aber ich bin der Vater,
der stets da war.
Ich schaute nach ihm bzw. ihr,
kümmerte mich um sie.
Dieser Vater bin ich.
Das ist einfach klar.
Ich gab mir auch immer Mühe,
keinen Unterschied zu den
anderen Geschwistern zu machen.
Josué und seine beiden Halbschwestern
sind noch klein,
als sich ihre Eltern
endgültig trennen.
Schon vor der Geburt des Jüngsten
legten sie eine Beziehungspause ein.
In dieser Pause wurde Josué gezeugt.
# Who do you think you are?
# Who do you think ...
Wann im Leben weiss man, wer man ist?
# Who do you think you are?
Nach der Trennung wächst Josué mit
den Schwestern bei der Mutter auf.
Den Vater
sehen sie mehrmals pro Woche.
Mit zwölf fängt Josué an,
weibliche Namen für sich auszudenken.
Was tun mit einem Jungen,
der sich als Mädchen fühlt?
Die Mutter sucht Hilfe beim Kinder-
und Jugendpsychiatrischen Dienst.
Ganz am Anfang,
als sie zu mir kam, fragte ich sie,
ob sie sich selbst zeichnen könnte.
Sie malte dieses Bild von sich
und sagte,
sie sei unter einer Tarnkappe.
Sie trug eine Mütze,
unter der sie ihre Haare versteckte.
Sie hatte lange Haare,
aber die sollte man nicht sehen.
Auf den Bauch,
nicht auf das T-Shirt,
malte sie ein trauriges Gesicht.
Sie befindet sich
sozusagen in der Jungenschale.
Sie sagte,
sie sei in eine Schale geschlüpft,
sei aber eigentlich ein Mädchen.
Dann sollte sie sich so malen,
wie sie es sich wünscht zu sein.
Damals zeichnete sie sich
unter verschiedene Namen:
Roxy, Elsa oder Soraja.
Da sieht man nun
eine ganz andere Soraya,
ein ganz anderes Kind -
fröhlich und lachend.
Das war ihr Wunsch,
wie sie eines Tages sein möchte.
Man hat 13 Jahre lang einen Jungen.
Und dann sollte man von einem Tag
auf den anderen akzeptieren,
dass plötzlich alles anders ist,
dass dieser Junge ein Mädchen ist.
Das ist wirklich schwierig
zu akzeptieren.
Ein halbes Jahr
ist seit dem Coming-out vergangen.
Schreibst du dich jetzt
mit Y oder J?
Mit Y.
J war nur eine Erinnerung an Josué.
Dann muss ich deinen Namen
auf meinem Handy ändern.
Ich erfuhr es an deiner
Geburtstagsparty.- Erst dort?
Ich glaubte zuerst,
du verarscht uns.
Es war mir nicht bewusst, dass es
Leute gibt, die so was haben.
Davon gehört hatte ich schon.
Aber mit dem Thema befasst
hatte ich mich nicht.
Wann kannst du frühestens
Östrogene nehmen?- Mit 14.
Sie machen etwas mit mir.
Ich nehme sie,
damit ich ein Mädchen werde.
Und dann
werde ich einen Freund haben.
Und die Operation?
Erst mit 16 Jahren.
18 Jahren.
- Nein, 16 Jahren.
Mit 16 Jahren kann man ...
- Soll ich warten bis 18?
Ja.
- Nein.
Und was ist,
wenn die Operation schiefgeht?
Die geht nicht schief.
Ich verstehe, dass sie das will,
aber ich finde es mit 16 sehr früh.
Und es kann bestimmt
auch viel schiefgehen.
Und man muss sich
voll im Klaren darüber sein.
Ich bin mir jetzt schon sicher.
Als ob ich euch fragen würde,
ob ihr ein Mann sein möchtet.
Das möchtet ihr doch auch nicht -
und ich ebenso wenig.
Aha, ja, so. Ja, so, so.
Salima, musst du nach Hause?
- Ja, es ist Zeit.
Welche Zeit haben wir?
- 20 vor.
Soraya
kann es nicht schnell genug gehen.
Eine Operation zur Anpassung
des Geschlechts bereits mit 16
hat es in der Schweiz
bis dato noch nicht gegeben.
Noch hofft ein Teil der Familie, dass
es überhaupt nie so weit kommen wird.
Wenn eine gute Fee kommen und sagen
würde, ich hätte drei Wünsche frei,
dann wäre wohl einer meiner Wünsche,
dass sich Soraya
wieder entscheiden würde,
ein Junge zu werden
oder ein Junge zu sein
und dass sie sich zu einem
gesunden, jungen Mann entwickelt.
Mama, regnet es heute?
Mühe mit Sorayas Coming-out
bekunden auch die beiden Schwestern.
Ich möchte
etwas Wimperntusche auftragen.
Sie möchten sich im Moment
noch nicht dazu äussern.
Wimperntusche und Lipgloss reichen.
- Es ist zu viel Lipgloss.
Du kannst nachher mit Papier, komm.
Das ist nicht der wasserfeste.
Also nicht die Augen reiben,
ist gut?
Das tue ich aber gerne.
Dann musst du eben ab und zu
zur Kontrolle ins Bad.
Das ist zu viel Lippenstift,
es glitzert zu sehr.
Zu viel Pink, zu viel alles.
Du hast dein Bett
nicht schön gemacht, Soraya.
Schau es dir doch an.
Ich habe es schön gemacht.
- Nein, schau mal.
Egal, ich gehe heute Abend
ja wieder ins Bett.
Das stimmt, aber schau doch mal.
Mach es ein wenig schöner.
Die Decke gerade ausrichten.
- Dafür habe ich keine Zeit.
Tschau, Mama.
- Tschüss. Mach's gut.
Danke für das Frühstück.
Schönen Tag.- Dir auch.
Soraya besucht die 2. Sekundarschule.
Es ist noch die gleiche Klasse,
in der sie im Frühling
ihr Coming-out hatte.
Seit dem Ende der Sommerferien
geht sie nicht mehr gerne hin.
Ich gehe generell
nicht gerne zur Schule.
Auf Mathe habe ich gar keine Lust.
Und die Schüler sind
auch nicht besonders nett zu mir.
Ausserdem habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich nach der Schule
nicht schlauer bin als vorher.
Das nervt mich.
Am meisten belastet sie aber
das Verhältnis zu den Jungs.
Zu Beginn akzeptierten sie es gut.
Aber in letzter Zeit
scheinen mich alle zu hassen.
Einer der Jungs
habe ihr neulich gesagt,
für ihn sei sie immer noch ein Junge.
Solle sie ihm doch
das Gegenteil beweisen.
* Leicht melancholische Popmusik *
Oh Gott, die Jungs sind nicht da.
Zu Beginn sagten die Jungs noch,
sie würden jeden,
der sie beleidige,
mit ihren Fäusten traktieren.
Aber nun sagen sie,
sie wollen Soraya verprügeln.
Die Jungs haben sich
ihr gegenüber geändert.
Soraya.
Die machen einen auf cool.
* Leicht melancholische Popmusik *
Eliana beginnt,
sich Sorgen zu machen.
Nicht nur, weil Sorayas Leistungen in
der Schule immer schlechter werden.
Letzte Woche ging sie mehrere Tage
nicht zur Schule.
Denn einige Kinder ...
... erinnern sie daran,
dass sie früher ein Junge war,
und können das
auch nicht mehr so gut akzeptieren.
Sie machen sie darauf aufmerksam,
dass sie
nicht wirklich ein Mädchen sei.
Das verletzt sie.
* Ruhige Klavierklänge *
Der erste Winter bricht an.
Die Anfeindungen in der Schule
nehmen nicht ab.
Die Eltern erwägen erstmals,
die Schule zu wechseln.
Soraya ist entschlossen,
ihren Weg weiterzugehen.
Sie ist jetzt 14.
Ihre offizielle Diagnose:
Geschlechtsinkongruenz.
Ihr gefühltes Geschlecht stimmt nicht
mit ihrem anatomischen überein.
Damit ihr Körper nicht
in die männliche Pubertät gerät,
muss sie regelmässig zum Arzt.
Hallo, Soraya. Wie geht's?
Ganz gut.
Es geht dir gut, super.
Und wie geht's mit den Spritzen?
Du hattest ja jetzt
schon einige Spritzen.
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Aber ich fühle mich wie ein Schwamm,
der alles aufsaugt.
Ah. Ja, genau.
Als ob ich
besonders viele Hormone hätte.
Das ist interessant.
Die Spritze bewirkt eigentlich das
Gegenteil, sie bremst die Hormone.
Aber es hat natürlich mit den
Hormonen zu tun. Das ist so.
Es ist einfach so ... Keine Ahnung.
Spürst du das anhand deiner Gefühle?
Wie spürst du das?
Ja, manchmal ...
Ich habe
seltsame Stimmungsschwankungen.
Die Spritze kann zu einem Mangel
von einigen Hormonen führen.
Das kann
zu Stimmungsschwankungen führen.
Ich trage extra
ein bauchfreies T-Shirt.
Das ist super, praktisch.
So sieht man auch
meinen fetten Bauch.
Alle zwei Wochen
erhält Soraya eine Spritze.
So.
(Arzt)
Wir haben Soraya Lucrin verabreicht.
Diese Spritze blockiert Hormone,
sowohl weibliche
als auch männliche Hormone.
So wird verhindert,
dass Soraya in die Pubertät gerät.
Man setzt die Spritze meistens ein,
um eine allzu frühe Pubertät
zu verhindern.
Bei Soraya ist es so,
dass sie dadurch mehr Zeit erhält,
um zu entscheiden,
in welche Richtung es gehen soll.
So.
Und schon fertig.
- Das ging schnell.
Das Thema Pubertätsblocker
habe ich bekämpft,
bis es nicht mehr ging.
Bis sich die KESB einschaltete
und quasi festlegte,
dass er diese Pubertätsblocker
erhalten müsse.
Ich hätte vermutlich
noch weitergekämpft ...
... aber ich hatte
keine Chance mehr.
Am Ende
hätte ich für nichts gekämpft.
Und irgendwie ...
Ich musste dabei
auch an Soraya denken.
Sie wäre letztlich
auch nicht glücklich gewesen,
wenn sie den Stimmbruch
bekommen hätte.
Die Mutter sah nicht nur
das Glück ihres Kindes gefährdet,
sondern dessen Überleben.
Wir sprachen einmal
über das Thema Pubertät,
dass er den Stimmbruch
bekommen würde und Bartwuchs.
Ein paar Tage später
kam er zu mir und sagte:
"Wenn ich den Stimmbruch bekomme,
möchte ich nicht mehr leben."
Sie spürte, dass zu ihrem Selbstbild
und ihren Selbstkonzepten,
wie sie sich sieht, wie sie ist,
dieser Stimmbruch nicht passt.
Dann sagte sie,
sie wolle nicht mehr leben.
Man kann nicht wissen,
ob das bei ihr passiert wäre.
Aber Untersuchungen zeigen,
dass ca. 70 % der Jugendlichen,
die Transgender sind, suizidal sind
oder sich selbst verletzen.
Das ist doch sehr viel,
und deswegen machte ich mir Sorgen.
An einen Tiefpunkt
gelangte die elterliche Beziehung,
als die Mutter die Kinderschutz-
behörde KESB einschaltete.
Aber schon vorher stellte Titus
die Absichten Elianas infrage.
Ich hatte lange Zeit das Gefühl,
dass vonseiten Elianas
ein wenig Manipulation im Spiel ist.
Sie stritt das immer ab, aber ich
konnte ihr das nie recht glauben.
Ich machte mir viele Gedanken,
ob das überhaupt möglich ist,
dass man ein Kind
ins andere Geschlecht erziehen kann.
Ich holte mir psychologische
Unterstützung und Beratung.
Mir wurde dann gesagt,
das könne man nicht.
Es ist ähnlich
wie mit der sexuellen Orientierung.
Wir wissen heute,
dass man die sexuelle Orientierung,
ob man auf Männer, Frauen
oder beides steht,
nicht mit Erziehung oder Druck
beeinflussen kann.
Mit der Geschlechtsidentität
verhält es sich ähnlich.
Soraya sieht aus wie ein Mädchen
und lebt wie ein Mädchen.
In den amtlichen Dokumenten
und auch im Busabo,
das sie manchmal vorweisen muss, ist
sie aber immer noch Josué, der Junge.
Um das zu ändern, muss sie
den Behörden einen Antrag schreiben.
Okay.
"Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren."
"Ich möchte meinen Namen
von Josué zu Soraya wechseln."
"Ich bin mir ganz sicher,
dass ich den Rest meines Lebens
als Frau verbringen möchte."
"Ich möchte auch keine Angst mehr
haben müssen, dass ich auffliege."
"Ich hoffe,
Sie nehmen sich das zu Herzen
und helfen mir,
vollkommen ein Mädchen zu werden."
"Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Zeit,
um meinen Brief zu lesen,
und wünsche Ihnen
ein schönes neues Jahr 2017."
"Liebe Grüsse, Soraya."
Das hast du gut geschrieben.
Das weiss ich doch nicht.
Du warst doch schon überall.
* Eindringlicher Popsong:
"When I Ride" von Moriarty *
Soraya
macht ihrem Vater keinen Vorwurf,
dass dieser lange
auf der Bremse stand.
Ich checke dich raus.
Oh mein Gott. Papa, warte!
Sie spürt, dass sein Widerstand
in letzter Zeit nachgelassen hat.
Wer zuletzt lacht, lacht am besten.
# Sometime may come,
you will get stung.
# And I, above ...
Titus will seinem Kind
nicht länger im Weg stehen.
Er hat erkannt,
dass er falsch lag mit der Vermutung,
es könnte bei Soraya bloss eine Phase
sein, von der Mutter gepusht.
# Higher than high above ...
Mir ist natürlich bewusst,
dass sie einst ein Junge war.
Das bleibt so in meinem Kopf.
Aber ... ich akzeptiere sie jetzt
als Mädchen.
Das kann ich so schon klar sagen.
Ja.
Was hat sich geändert? Wieso akzep-
tierst du Soraya heute als Mädchen?
Weil ...
... Zeit vergangen ist,
die ich benötigte.
Ich musste mich daran gewöhnen,
auch an dieses Gefühl,
dass mein Junge kein Junge mehr ist,
sondern ein Mädchen,
bzw. sich als Mädchen fühlt.
Ich sehe ja ...
... wie sicher sie sich ist.
Lange Zeit wusste ich nicht,
ob plötzlich wieder
eine andere Phase kommen würde
und sie sich nicht mehr sicher ist.
Ich finde es voll süss.
Nein, nicht filmen.- Doch.
- Spinnst du?
Das haben mir die Leute
von der Doku ...
Schau doch nicht so, sonst
kommt das noch in die Doku rein.
Sie gaben mir die Kamera,
damit ich filmen kann,
was sie selber nicht sehen können,
wenn sie nicht dabei sind.
Ein schönes Gesicht.
Eins, zwei drei!
Kamera aus.
* Abwartende Klänge *
Sorayas Körper entwickelt sich wegen
der Spritzen zwar nicht zum Mann,
aber ohne weibliche Hormone
auch nicht zur Frau.
Soraya möchte sich deshalb
Östrogene verschreiben lassen.
Die gängige Praxis des Kinderspitals
ist allerdings: warten bis 16.
Wir dürfen das Gespräch nicht filmen.
Die Ärztin
bietet Soraya einen Kompromiss an:
noch ein Jahr
statt der üblichen zwei Jahre warten.
Erstens habe ich keinen Bock,
noch ein weiteres Jahr zu warten.
Zweitens finde ich: Es ist
mein Leben und meine Verantwortung.
Sie könnten mir die Hormone
doch schon jetzt geben.
Und wenn es dann falsch war,
bin ich selber schuld.
Wenn ich mir jetzt sicher bin,
dass ich sie jetzt haben will ...
Dann auch noch in einem Jahr.
- Ja, und auch in 30 Jahren.
Ich finde es bescheuert,
dass man für eine so kleine Pille
stundenlang Termine machen muss.
Die Folgen einer Östrogenabgabe
sind allerdings nicht umkehrbar.
Im Gegensatz
zur pubertätsblockierenden Spritze,
die wieder abgesetzt werden kann.
Vielleicht
findet sich ein anderer Arzt.
Bis dahin müssen die Probleme
anderweitig gelöst werden.
* Eindringlicher Popsong:
"Diamonds Never Die" von Moriarty *
Hallo.
- Soraya.
Hallo, ich bin Eliana.
# Yonder line of naked trees ...
Ich glaube, du bist etwas zu jung
für so hohe Absätze.
#  Diamonds never die.
Du benötigst keine Perücke,
du hast so schöne Haare.
Das funktioniert so:
Die Genitalien
werden in eine Tasche gesteckt.
Da es in der Mitte
unten festgenäht ist,
werden die Genitalien
zwischen die Beine gezogen.
Wir bräuchten v.a. Badehosen,
also ein Bikini-Oberteil.
Die Mädchen in der Pubertät
bekommen jetzt Oberweite.
Sie ist die Einzige,
die noch keine hat.
Gibt es da etwas mit Pölsterchen,
Badehosen oder Bikinis?
Ich zeige mal, wie das aussieht.
Kommen die da rein?
Genau. Das wird von der Innenseite
in die Tasche gesteckt.
So etwa.
Dann sieht das aus, als wäre es
ein Stück vom eigenen Körper.
Ja, sieht ziemlich echt aus.
Sollte sie tatsächlich im Wasser
rausrutschen, geht sie nicht unter,
sondern schwimmt oben auf.
Also kann man ein normales Bikini,
ein Push-up-Bikini kaufen?
Das muss nicht sein.
Wichtig ist, dass es gut hält.
Käme so etwas für dich infrage?
Hauptsache grosse Brüste!
Such dir aus,
was du gerne probieren möchtest.
Diese?
Wir ziehen den Vorhang zu.
Sind die kalt!
Platzen die,
wenn ich im Turnunterricht hinfalle?
Nein, eben nicht.
Aber cool ist es.
- Ehrlich?
Ja, megageil!
Ich finde sie etwas gross.
- Ja, schon.
Gut, mit 14 gibt es ...
- Nein, es sieht sehr unecht aus.
Ich finde sie viel zu gross.
So lustig.
Das macht dermassen Spass.
Es kommt eher nicht infrage.
Ich probiere noch
eine kleinere Grösse.
Und schwups,
da ist wieder die alte Soraya.
Schau,
wie männlich dieser Körper ist.
Jetzt noch.
Ich möchte das nicht.
* Eindringlicher Popsong *
# Yonder line of naked trees.
Yonder burn the thousand winds.
Diese wirken viel natürlicher.
# Diamonds never die.
Schau dich mal im Spiegel an.
Wie nimmst du dich selbst wahr?
Kaufen wir sie?
Ich möchte das
noch mit Papa besprechen.
Das war jetzt mal
ein erster Eindruck für dich.
Du hattest zuvor noch nie Brüste.
Papa kann es doch egal sein,
ob ich Brüste habe oder nicht.
Es ist ihm nicht egal.
- Es ist mein Körper!
Das stimmt, aber es ist unser Geld.
Es ist mein Recht, mit meinem Körper
anzustellen, was ich will.
Das ist klar. Ich möchte ja,
dass du dich wohlfühlst.
Ich verstehe auch,
dass du diese Brüste brauchst,
um dich noch weiblicher zu fühlen.
Ich möchte aber Papa nicht aus-
schliessen, ihn weiter einbeziehen.
Frag ihn, ob er es sich
erst anschauen möchte, Soraya.
Ich komme vorbei
und du kannst sie dir anschauen.
Und wenn du sie hässlich findest,
lege ich sie halt in mein Zimmer.
Okay, ist gut. Dann kaufen ich sie.
Danke, du bist ein Schatz, tschüss.
Darf ich auch noch mit ihm sprechen?
Er hat schon aufgelegt.
Der Frühling wird zum Sommer,
und dieser weicht dem Herbst.
* Sanfte Musik *
Eliana und Soraya
sind in ein neues Zuhause gezogen.
Soraya wird bald 16.
Die ersehnten Östrogene hat sie
unterdessen längst bekommen.
Die Probleme mit den Jungs indes
dauerten an.
Soraya
hat deshalb die Schule gewechselt.
Wir haben 10-Uhr-Pause,
deswegen gehe ich ein Stück.
Es ist megakalt.
Ich bin mit einer Freundin hier.
Ich filme bloss deine Schuhe.
Meine Schuhe sind aber dreckig.
Ab in den Mülleimer mit der Kamera.
Es gibt zwei hübsche Jungs
in meiner Schule.
Der eine bekam die
mit den "grossen Melonen".
Bei ihr ist alles unecht,
von oben bis unten.
Die beiden sind zusammen,
er fällt damit weg.
Dann bleibt noch ein hübscher Junge.
Dann komme ich daher und versuche,
einigermassen schön auszusehen,
trotz meines Nachteils,
es ist wirklich ein Nachteil.
Und wenn einer mal Interesse hat,
dann musst du ehrlich zu ihm sein.
Mal ehrlich: Finde einen Jungen,
der schön ist, im richtigen Alter
und nicht gleich davonrennt,
wenn du es ihm erzählst.
Am neuen Ort
wusste zunächst nur die Schulleitung,
dass sie als Junge zur Welt kam.
Niemand schöpfte Verdacht.
Weil Soraya dann doch
ein, zwei Mitschülerinnen einweihte,
riet ihr die Schule, sich bei allen
als Transmädchen zu outen.
Prompt
führte das wieder zu Anfeindungen.
Eine Psychologin hilft Soraya,
damit umzugehen.
Darf ich mich aufs Sofa setzen?
In der Schule läuft es wie immer.
Es ist ziemlich anstrengend
mit den Jungs.
Mit den Mädchen
läuft es dafür umso besser.
Mit dem Mädchen läuft es gut?
- Ja.
Kennst du das schon,
seit du klein warst?
Nein, in meiner ersten Schule,
in der 1. und 2. Klasse,
hatte ich sehr viele Freunde.
Also erst nach dem Wechsel zu Soraya
begannen die Probleme mit den Jungs.
Davor gab's keine grossen Probleme.
- Ja.
Von Jungs höre ich immer wieder,
dass sie darüber diskutieren müssen,
ob ich überhaupt menschlich bin
oder was ich genau bin.
So: "Nein ich bin ein Alien,
pass auf, ich stecke dich an
mit meiner grausamen Krankheit."
Deswegen ... Ich weiss auch nicht.
Sorayas Weg in die Freiheit droht
zum Weg in die Ausgrenzung zu werden.
Man ist einfach immer anders
als alle anderen.
Das macht keinen Spass,
denn anders bedeutet auch einsam.
Ich möchte kein Transgender sein,
sondern ein Mädchen.
Ein Mädchen wie jedes andere -
das ist mein Ziel.
Mein Ziel ist nicht, dass alle
wissen, dass ich transgender bin.
Und wie passt das zusammen,
wenn wir jetzt einen Film über dich
drehen und deine Geschichte erzählen,
dass du als Junge geboren wurdest
und jetzt ein Mädchen bist?
Damit will ich andere unterstützen.
Andere Menschen,
andere Transgender,
die diesen Film schauen,
wussten zuvor vielleicht nicht,
wie damit umgehen
oder was das überhaupt genau ist.
Wenn sie meine Geschichte sehen,
wie sich das entwickelt hat,
könnte das ihnen Hoffnung machen,
dass sie das auch erreichen können.
Hallo, Soraya.
Wir können gleich beginnen.
Soraya wiederholt
die 2. Sekundarschule.
Die grössten Defizite
hat sie in Mathematik
aufgrund einer Dyskalkulie.
Nachhilfe gibt ihr der Schulleiter.
Machen wir da weiter,
wo wir vorgestern aufgehört haben.
Was war das letzte Thema?
Dreiecke berechnen?
- Ja, Steigungen.
Aha, Prozente.
- Genau, das ist die Steigung.
Aber was bringt mir das jetzt?
- Dazu kommen wir gleich.
Ihre Motivation
hängt sehr stark davon ab,
was sie gerne tut und was nicht,
was sie einsieht oder nicht.
"Brauche ich das fürs Leben
oder nicht?"
Wenn sie das Gefühl hat,
sie brauche etwas nicht,
es sei anstrengend und mühsam,
dann ist sie sehr wenig motiviert.
Das ist schon eine Schwierigkeit
in der Gesellschaft.
Ich muss noch kurz
die Fortsetzung holen.
Es gibt noch eine Fortsetzung?
Es gibt noch mehr Übungen,
du bist erst am Anfang.
Juhu!
Ich hole mal die anderen Blätter.
Dass Sorayas Probleme
mit den Mitschülern
allein auf ihre Transidentität
zurückzuführen sind,
sieht der Schulleiter skeptisch.
Die Grundeinstellung der Kinder,
die das wissen, ist sehr, sehr gut.
Wenn es untereinander Probleme gibt,
hat es nichts damit zu tun.
Für sie wird es wohl schon
immer wieder eine Rolle spielen.
Das ist ihr Alltag,
und er ist sehr präsent.
Wenn es jemand
nicht gut mit ihr hat,
führt sie das Problem darauf zurück.
Manchmal ist es aber
wegen etwas ganz anderem.
Soraya weiss, dass sie aneckt.
Vielleicht
rührt ihr innerer Zorn daher,
dass ihr das Frauwerden
zu langsam vorangeht.
Wir machen
sowieso nicht alle Seiten.
Ich habe neue Tabletten.
Langsam sollte es
etwas schneller gehen.
Ich nehme diese Tabletten
nun schon seit eineinhalb Jahren.
Es hat sich bisher
nicht so viel getan. Egal.
Es geht mir zu langsam.
Deswegen dachte ich,
ich nehme statt drei ein paar mehr.
Das dürfte ich eigentlich nicht -
also nicht nachmachen.
Wie viele soll ich nehmen? Vier?
Die ist auch schon fast draussen,
fünf.
Ich nehme sieben statt drei.
Die sind eh so klein, deswegen ...
Igitt.
Die sind viel ekliger
als meine alten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist kurz vor Weihnachten.
Sorayas älteste Schwester Naomi
ist zu Besuch.
Es wäre hilfreich gewesen,
wenn du den Puderzucker
gleichmässig verteilt hättest.
So machst du noch mehr Löcher,
nimm diese doch weg.
So habe ich das noch nie gesehen.
Tja, ich bin eben einzigartig.
Unsere Backkünste sind es auch.
So.
Jetzt können wir ausstechen.
Wir sehen uns nicht so oft,
weil ich schon lange
nicht mehr zu Hause wohne.
Ich bin ausgezogen,
als du elf Jahre alt warst.
Sie war jetzt einige Male
am Wochenende bei uns zu Hause.
Das war megalustig.
Sie kommt uns auch oft besuchen.
Naomi wollte zunächst
nicht im Film mitmachen,
wie auch ihre jüngere Schwester
Sharlyn nicht.
Sorayas Transidentität hatte
die Familie zeitweise gespalten.
Sharlyn, Papa und ich waren
zu Beginn nicht davon überzeugt,
dass sie tatsächlich transgender
bzw. ein Mädchen ist.
Wir dachten, es könnte
auch bloss eine Phase sein,
dass es um Aufmerksamkeit
oder Identitätsfindung geht.
Ich hatte oft Streit mit Mama,
weil ich das Gefühl hatte,
sie pushe das ein wenig,
salopp gesagt.
Im Nachhinein
bin ich aber fast froh,
dass sie das Thema aufgenommen
und Soraya unterstützt hat.
Wäre es nicht so gewesen,
wäre sie alleine dagestanden.
Ich bin zwar noch der Meinung,
etwas weniger hätte auch genügt.
Aber hier sind wir nun.
Ich glaube, das alles hat unserem
kleinen Familienkreis gut getan.
Die Auseinandersetzung
in der Familie gehört dazu.
Die Meinungen und der Wissenstand
waren unterschiedlich.
Es ist ein Prozess,
der Zeit benötigt.
Weihnachten im Kreis der Familie.
Was ist das?
Mama, du sollst nicht filmen,
wie du mir Unterwäsche schenkst.
Mama, also wirklich!
Solche ziehst du doch gerne an,
nicht?
Süss, nicht?
- Die sind ja transparent.
Nein.
Du trägst ja jetzt auch solche.
- Danke.
* Dynamische Popmusik *
Kurz nach Weinachten
ist Sorayas Geburtstag.
Sie wird 16.
Sie hat auch zwei, drei Jungs
eingeladen, die haben aber abgesagt.
Wer steht lieber im Mittelpunkt?
Wem ist Geld wichtiger?
Wenn ich im Lotto gewinnen würde,
würde ich mir ein Schloss kaufen.
Eine typische Soraya-Antwort.
Zuerst ein Schloss,
dann Angestellte ...
dann einen Stall mit Pferd,
dann vielleicht ein Auto, dann ein
Privatjet, dann eine Angestellte.
Wer ist sexuell aktiver?
Okay, eine etwas blöde Frage.
Anuschka!
* Türklingel *
Ich öffne dir.
Tritt auf die obere Stufe,
dann sind wir gleich gross.
* Dynamische Popmusik *
Mit 16
könne sie sich operieren lassen,
hoffte Soraya
beim Coming-out vor zwei Jahren.
Noch ist dieses Ziel nicht in Sicht.
Soraya wollte Brüste, Po
und Vagina bekommen,
weiblich werden.
Umso erstaunter sind wir,
als sie beim nächsten Besuch
ihre Haare abgeschnitten hat.
Ich war zu Besuch
bei einer Freundin.
Ich spielte schon länger mit
dem Gedanken, die Haare zu kürzen.
Sie hat mich fast dazu gezwungen:
"Komm, wir machen das jetzt!"
Ich willigte ein.
Sie hat mir die Haare abrasiert,
und jetzt sind sie eben weg.
Wie gefällst du dir?
Ganz gut.
Zu Beginn war ich etwas schockiert,
denn ich sah ein wenig Josué in mir,
den Jungen.
Aber ich sagte dann zu mir:
"Ich bin schön, so wie ich bin."
Und es gibt auch Frauen
mit kurzen Haaren, die schön sind.
In jüngster Zeit macht sie sich
vermehrt Gedanken über ihre Herkunft
und ihren leiblichen Vater,
den Papai.
Mein Papai in Brasilien
wäre wegen eines Motorradunfalls
fast gestorben.
Ich muss mit ihm Frieden schliessen.
Ich sah ihn zuletzt
mit sieben Jahren.
Ich muss mit ihm Frieden schliessen.
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Ich fühle mich von ihm irgendwie
verlassen, ich weiss auch nicht.
* Exotisch anmutende Discomusik *
Whoa!
Genau das ist Brasilien -
nicht diese São-Paulo-Scheisse.
Sorayas Schwester Sharlyn
ist mitgekommen
auf die Reise nach Brasilien.
Eliana hat in ihrem Mutterland
eine grosse Familie.
Soraya war vor neun Jahren
das letzte Mal hier.
Letztes Mal war hier noch nichts.
Auch Sharlyn benötigte Zeit,
um Sorayas Weg zu akzeptieren.
Ich hatte mit dem Gefühl gehadert,
einen Bruder verloren zu haben.
Zumindest zu Beginn.
Jetzt sehe ich es so: Josué ist
gestorben und dafür ist Soraya da.
Das ist für mich völlig in Ordnung.
* Sanfter Popsong *
Soraya hatte bis jetzt keinen Kontakt
zum biologischen Vater,
auch ihre Mutter nur lose.
Wenn Vater, Verwandte und Familie
noch leben,
finde ich es wichtig,
dass ein Kind weiss, woher es kommt,
Ich weiss natürlich nicht,
wie er reagieren wird.
Wann und ob der Besuch
beim Vater möglich sein wird,
bleibt tagelang unklar.
Wenn es ihm etwas bedeuten würde,
hätte er ja mal einen Brief zu
meinem Geburtstag schreiben können.
Ich glaube, er weiss nicht mal,
wann ich Geburtstag habe.
Für die Mutter ist es ein Heimkommen,
für die Tochter
eine Reise in ihr Innerstes.
Ihr biologischer Vater
hat hier eine eigene Familie.
Man verabredet sich
deshalb bei Verwandten.
Hallo, kleine Cousine, wir haben uns
lange nicht gesehen. Sei willkommen.
Du riechst gut.
Ich bin auch frisch geduscht.
Gegen Mitternacht
taucht auch Sorayas Vater auf.
Er arbeitet in einer Fabrik.
Mit ihm hatte Eliana
eine flüchtige Beziehung.
Sie liess ihn wissen,
dass aus dem gemeinsamen Sohn Josué
eine Tochter geworden ist.
Gut sehe sie aus, findet er.
Bist du betrunken? Oh mein Gott!
Soraya spricht kein Brasilianisch.
Er sah sie mit sieben Jahren
zum letzten Mal.
Er sei etwas erschrocken,
es habe ihn etwas traurig gemacht.
Dich doch auch.
- Ja, auch ich war traurig.
Mama, schau mal,
wir haben die gleichen Handlinien.
Tatsächlich.
Oh mein Gott, hier ebenfalls.
Okay.
Ich hätte nicht erwartet,
dass es sich so gut anfühlt.
Ich weiss jetzt,
von wem ich was habe.
Der Papa in der Schweiz
war immer für mich da
und tat alles für mich.
Er ist der Papa meines Herzens.
Aber der Papai
ist mein körperlicher Vater,
der mir meinen Körper gab,
mir das Leben schenkte.
Das habe ich schon gemerkt.
* Exotisch anmutende Discomusik *
"Troféu do Ano"
von Jerry Smith & MC Nando DK *
Soraya hat Antworten
zu ihrer Vergangenheit gefunden.
Drängender noch
sind ihre Fragen zur Zukunft.
Sie spricht seit Langem davon,
sich operieren zu lassen.
Dafür braucht es
ein Gutachten der Psychiaterin.
Dann setze ich mich dorthin.
Ja, herzlich willkommen.
Es geht um ein Thema,
das dir sehr wichtig ist.
Wir haben vereinbart, dass wir heute
auch über diese Operation sprechen,
die du dir wünschst.
Es wird wohl auch
ein befreiendes Gefühl sein,
wenn ich ins Freibad gehen kann,
ohne immer aufzupassen.
Ich glaube,
ich würde mich normaler fühlen.
Und jetzt möchte ich die Operation.
Ich möchte die Eltern nun bitten,
den Raum zu verlassen
und draussen zu warten,
denn du entscheidest
über ein sehr persönliches Thema.
Wir sprechen erst mal
unter vier Augen.
Dann können Sie wieder kommen.
Ich weiss, Sie wissen alles
und sind stets im Gespräch,
aber trotzdem ...
Ist das okay?
Sie ist ein Teenager,
wir wissen auch nicht mehr alles.
Soraya soll erfahren,
was der Eingriff medizinisch bedeutet
und wie lange
die Heilung dauern wird.
Ist sie schon bereit dafür?
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir haben das gemeinsam besprochen.
Sag mal,
was du selbst dazu gemeint hast.
Ich habe gesagt,
wenn die Operation
schon morgen stattfinden würde,
könnte ich das
wohl nicht durchziehen.
Aber wenn man die Operation
Anfang Winter durchführen könnte,
nach meinem 17. Geburtstag,
dann könnte ich das
schon durchstehen.
Weil du noch zur Schule gehst
und keine Zeit hast?
Auch, weil ich jetzt
noch Angst davor habe.
So hätte ich
noch ein halbes Jahr Zeit,
um mich darauf vorzubereiten
und Kraft dafür aufzubauen.
Ich fände es gut,
wenn du noch mehr Informationen
von operierten Transfrauen
einholen würdest,
damit du dir das
noch besser vorstellen kannst,
wie das ist und was es braucht,
damit Soraya sich entscheiden kann,
ob sie sich das zutraut.
Als Eltern können Sie
sie zwar unterstützen,
aber letztlich
musst du das selbst durchstehen.
Es gibt noch einen anderes Thema,
das wir gemeinsam besprechen müssen.
Es ist nicht sicher,
dass die Krankenkasse bezahlt.
Grundsätzlich müssen sie zahlen,
denn es ist Katalog.
Und wenn die Diagnose
wie in diesem Fall klar ist ...
Es ist eher
eine Frage des Zeitpunktes.
Es gibt kein Gesetz,
das die Krankenkasse verpflichtet,
schon in diesem Alter zu bezahlen.
Super. Gut.
- Gut.
In der nächsten Folge:
Die Operation wird konkret.
Bei der Operation
werden die Hoden entfernt.
Und sie droht zu scheitern.
Wir seien mit der Grundversicherung
nicht gedeckt.
Solange ich nicht operiert bin, bin
ich ein Junge in Mädchenkleidern.
Doch aufgeben
ist für Soraya keine Option.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2022